um if you would all please join me
before we start and say the pledgees of
Allegiance
IED algi to the the United States of
America and to the Republic for it
stands one nation under God indivisible
liberty and justice for
all good morning everyone and Welcome to
our subcommittee work session ongoing
session regarding bail reform today
we're going to be
discussing the actual list of crime s
that we're contemplating being not
bailable by bail
commissioner and you just give me a
minute to call it up we will start with
that few housekeeping things first uh
this is for the members of the committee
um right now I'm working on setting up a
meeting with the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court to discuss our bill issues
and keeping with my commitment to make
sure this is a nonpartisan event I will
be taking uh a member probably I'm going
to ask representative gathri to attend
or representative
Muse um I'm also working on a meeting
hopefully next week with the attorney
general same thing applies I've asked
the um that the um attorneys for the
county uh come and join us and I've also
extending an invitation to the public
defenders to come and talk to
us um each of these things that I've
mentioned are all part of this bail
reform there's so many moving parts so
we all have to keep in mind that any
change we do however small to this
affects four or five different parts of
our criminal justice system and each one
of those within their agencies are
affected so it's very complex a lot of
moving parts so we have to be very
deliberative in what we do for
example if we contemplate having judges
hear cases on a weekend you think okay
judge has to be able to come in or do a
zoom hearing on the
weekend well not just the judge it's
also the
clerks the clerks have to be able to
take take notes of the of everything
that's happening to enter into their
systems the clerks are union to have
them work on a weekend it's going to
cause impa bargaining to open up their
contract very complex stuff so that's
why it's important that we disc discuss
and invite as many people as we can so
that we understand the long range
implications of every little change we
make so let's talk about
crimes and if I could just find that
[Music]
list is that the one from the
sen
it yeah okay very good thank you so
much all right so I'm going to be
working off uh
s252 as proposed by the
Senate and we're going to look at their
list of crimes that they would like to
be not bailable by a bail
commissioner and the first on the list
this person charged with
homicide I don't think we really have to
include that because it's already got
its own statute and it's not bailable so
we can probably just cross that one off
anyone have any thoughts on
that
anyone is there a disadvantage to
putting it on there making it
redundant um no there's not um other
than the fact that it's it makes looked
like we didn't know it was already there
but um we can we can leave it for now
and put a pin in it and talk about about
it when we draft the final one if you
want
um what's
that no he has2 SB
252 uh the next one we talk about is um
first degree assault under RSA 631 can
you call that statute up so as we go
along I can we can actually read
it RSA
one
could you uh would you read it for us
y um RSA 6311 first degree assault a
person is guilty of a class a felony if
he or she I will go ahead and add that
purposely cause a serious bodily injury
to another or purposely or knowingly
causes bodily injury to another by means
of a deadly
weapon except that if that deadly weapon
is a firearm he shall be sentenced in
accordance with RSA
6512 purposely or knowingly causes
injury to another resulting in a
miscarriage or a still birth or
knowingly or recklessly causes serious
bodily injury to a person under 13 years
of age in this section and then it goes
on to describe a miscarriage or a still
birth thank you so the question for us
is does does that crime in and of itself
um characterize or or um lead one to
believe that that person were they
released would be a danger to the public
um I I I I tend to agree that that's a
very serious and violent crime and it
should be heard by a judge and not
released by a bail commissioner um what
are the committee's
thoughts uh representative
Muse yes as we go through this it would
be very helpful uh if when we're looking
at the statute we could just uh ALS Alo
mention uh what the the penalty is so
for this one it's obviously a felony uh
some of the others it's not so obvious
uh so it would just be helpful if we
just mentioned that going
forward agreed we will make sure we call
out whether it's a felony or not or if a
certain degree of it is a felony because
some of them for example stalking have a
misdemeanor level and a felony level so
we we'll call that out um as we go um
with regard to this one so anyone else
representative Stone Mr Mr chairman I
would uh concur with your assessment of
it everyone seems in agreement that
one's pretty clearcut uh the next one is
uh RSA excuse me second degree assault
RSA
okay 6312 second degree assault a person
is guilty of a class B
felony if he or she knowingly recklessly
causes serious bodily injury to another
or recklessly causes bodily injury to
another by means of a deadly weapon
except if that deadly weapon is a
firearm he or she shall be
sentenced in looks like section two
recklessly causes bodily injury to
another under circumstances manifesting
extreme indifference to the value of
human life or purposely or knowly causes
bodily injury to a child under 13 years
of age recklessly or negligently causes
injury to another resulting in
miscarriage or stillbirth or purposely
or knowingly engages in the strength
ation of another in this section and
then it goes on to describe miscarriage
sto birth and
strangulation um Mr chairman it does go
on to say upon proof that the victim and
defendant were intimate Partners or
family of household members or those
terms are defined in RSA
632b um shall be recorded as second
deegree assault under the domestic
violence thank you so that it seems to
me the the element um that's different
in this one is it's
Reckless versus um
intentional can you read that part again
it talks about um it talks about
indifference yeah hold on one second let
me find
it please
hold wait I can't find it now
oh okay it's under C recklessly causes
bodily injury to another under
circumstances manifesting extreme
indifference to the value of human
life thank you any uh thoughts on this
one um so this this also seems very
serious um versus apparently versus um
planning it out or intentionally someone
did something so reckless that that um
that a normal person would would never
um contemplate doing something like that
and in doing such an act they caused
serious bodily injury to another person
again um someone who was so reckless
that they caused such serious bodily
injury in my mind raises serious
questions about their um ability to um
maintain themselves in good order and
not be a danger to the public due to
their recklessness in in whatever the
case is it's a felon
um let's hear some thoughts from the
committee representative
Muse one of the things as we as we go
through this list I think pretty much
looking at this list I mean I think we
would probably come to the conclusion
that all of these are are pretty pretty
serious offenses I think the question is
um um what do we do with this list you
know and kind of Where Do We Go From
Here uh and and so
if you look at it if you know I mean if
you if you look at it one way you know
at the end of this process we might have
the same list of very serious crimes
that we had when we when we started if
we look at it from from a from a
different perspective so so for for
example if um the maximum time a person
could be held without uh a hearing
before a judge was significantly
significantly reduced then uh it becomes
a lot easier to have uh a more
comprehensive list um but if if there's
no movement on something like that then
you really would want to make a an
effort to filter this down to a list of
the the most serious of the serious
crimes I tend to agree and I think we're
we're probably thinking along the same
um same
track um I I I look at the whole list
and I see you know these are all very
serious
crimes that um speak for themselves
about someone being dangerous if they
would do one of them however I I also
agree that they are innocent to proven
guilty so we have to make sure that if
they are held it's for a limited period
of time with that in mind um I had
contemplated discussing with the
committee
setting a um a requirement on the courts
to hold a a hearing on a weekend be it
via Zoom electronically however so that
someone's not held more than 24 hours
without having access to a judge to at
least listen to their their case um I
know our sister state to the South
Massachusetts they have something
similar called the Jenkins rule if
someone's going to be held one in 24
hours they have to run it by a judge on
the weekend to phone callers Zoom call
that way the defendant has at least had
a set of eyes on it besides the
commissioner um and then he just makes a
quick decision yeah hold him and then
they arraign him and deal with it on
Monday or he says n you know that's kind
of weak let him go so at least I feel
like I agree with you that if we're
going to keep a comprehensive list then
we need to make sure that people have
access to someone besides just in the
police station any further thoughts
representative Pratt I agree with the
chairman uh salt should be on the list
any other thoughts that's it I know that
we have a representative here from the
police today would you like to give
share your input on on our thoughts on
this uh Dan Conley from the gtown police
department uh specifically you just
asking about the second degree assault
or or the whole if if you would mind
just I'm sure you've had a chance to
look at the list of crimes what are your
thoughts on on the on the crimes we have
listed is it comprehensive enough or do
you feel like some of them may be not
necessary I believe they're all um
necessary to be in there they're if you
look at the crimes there they all are
either violent
felonies um the the two that aren't
felonies it's it's domestic violence and
um
stalking and those are two very serious
crimes with a you know high percentage
for lethality just due to the um danger
that these crimes pose to the victims of
those crimes of domestic violence and
stalking and stalking if it is it can be
a
felony the misdemeanor the majority of
ones um that you see prosecuted as a
misdemeanor it's usually for
violating a no contact order within a
previous bail um so if you look at a
stalking a majority of the charges for
violating that no contact provision from
uh bail under 597
so they're already out on bail and then
they're being charged with stalking
because they're contacting the victim
that they're usually under for um
domestic violence and that's just the
district court part of
it
and and the other ones you know the of
course the sexual assaults and the uh
kidnapping and trafficking they're just
um we we believe uh from the Chiefs
Association and just my personal thing I
believe they all are pose a huge danger
to victim in the
public thank you um can have can you
tell us what if any experience you've
had working with the bail Commissioners
on these crimes have you seen people
being let go on
these just from the I I'll I'll speak
just on the domestic violence and
stalking as misdemeanor yes um majority
of times more likely than not they're
getting the pr bail under domestic
violence if you are charged with
domestic violence they will get a
quicker arraignment date than a um you
know say a regular ndv simple assault
they'll be arraigned within you know
within Pro usually the next um available
Court dat but in some some courts that
could be a week or two just because
there's no
judge um you don't often
see
um it's very rare to see someone held on
a misdemeanor domestic violence or
misdemeanor
stalking and when stalking is
charged for violating a no contact
provision within a
bail um it's very similar to VI
violation of protection order in
violation protection order there's no
bail but for stalking they get bail so
the majority of time they'll be
PR thank you does anyone have any
questions for the
captain representative
Stone thank you Mr chairman in your
experience uh when someone's released on
PR bail for domestic misdemeanor say
simple assault how often do you see them
violating the bail on those cases in
your
experience I I I don't have a a number
for you or a percentage but it
it's it's
common
because they have a
relationship and and and more often than
not they try to contact them somehow um
so it's
not I I wouldn't say it's every single
one I wouldn't say it's every other one
but it's it's it's more common than not
you see it routin
teely thank you is it is it true that um
the most dangerous time for a victim of
domestic violence is when they try to
leave their abuser and which usually
starts with the first arrest like
this yes and domestic violence charges
just they pose a huge danger to the
victim because um speaking from my
experience and working with victims when
the police are finally at the house
making an arrest it's not the first time
that that victim has experienced um
violence from their partner by the time
we get there it's it's been it's usually
an ongoing thing and the victim finally
had enough to call
and I I I'm not a domestic violence
expert I'm not you know I don't work for
um one of the organizations that deal
specifically with victims that's just
from my
experience thank you um is there
anything you'd like to oh excuse me go
ahead thank you Mr
chairman you had mentioned when you go
when you go to a home you know it's not
the first time that that this has
happened it just escalated to this point
how many times do you have to go to a
home when a concerned neighbor or
somebody you know just happens to be
maybe going past that house and can hear
obviously something is not right when
the victim themselves is not able to
call that that happens a lot uh
especially in you know we have a you
know come uh apartment complexes the
neighbor will call um because they can
hear the damage being done in the house
or they see something or hear something
that that happens often times and um you
know that is the victims you often when
we show up they're very nervous because
someone else called and they you know
they're they're nervous of what's going
to happen now when we
leave represent
Muse yeah to
to what ex to what extent um you know
when you take a look at at sort of like
the kind of like all all of these cases
you kind of you kind of put them all
together
um one of the things that I'm um trying
to work through in in in my own head are
the the percentage of of people who or
or let's say violators who are
um let's say released uh after a
domestic violence charge so maybe a
firsttime or some something like that
and and who go back and and who are are
almost immediately in contact uh with
their spouse again or with whoever they
committed the act of domestic violence
again so I guess my question is is how
common is it for somebody who's been
charged to just go right back to the
well and do it all over again very
common very and a lot of times the
victims will not notify us that either
the defendant has come
home to where they are or um is
contacting them in some sort of way the
majority of time um we end up you know
arresting them for violating the bail
order or charging them with stalking as
usually we see them
with them or we see them at the house or
we get called there again for another
crime and he's there or she's there and
they bail against being at that person's
house or within contact with them you
what when they get on we see it a lot of
times is when you start going for
domestic cause you you end up going to
that same
address repeatedly because they're in a
cycle of violence and you're just going
Time After Time After Time and it's the
same
people it's the same victims it's the
defendant thank you Cam do you for the
benefit of the members of the committee
who don't have a lot of criminal law
experience could you tell us about the
power of of of the police to charge um
even if the victim doesn't want a a case
brought yeah we we can
um based on what the officers observe if
they observe injuries um you know they
observe a you know a red mark on the
face even if the victim is not going to
you know the the police officers can
kind of put some some evidence together
you know but you can still go forward
with a charge where the victim is uh
unwilling to you know testify against
that defendant due to um you know mostly
what the officer observes when he gets
he or she gets to that scene you know if
there's there is an injury if there's
marks um you can still make a charge go
forward and work without that victim's
cooperation thank you
um since I have you here I'm going to um
ask you a few other questions regarding
the bail in general um with regard to
what we're discussing though right now
the um so bail Commissioners will let
people go on PR in your experience um
but that is also in keeping with the way
the current statute's written is it not
ye yes we rarely see a cash bail unless
it's um by Statute for violation of uh
protection order excuse me or
um you you know it's such a it's very
very rare to see a cash bail um very
rare even on these felonies even on
these violent felonies first degree
assault second degree assault um
barring some you know exceptional
situation they're going to get PR
bail and just so the committee
understands it's it's not the bail
commissioner's fault I mean this is the
stat this is why we have to change the
statute right I I agree and you know
I I would I would actually like to you
know felony Reckless conduct we see
oftentimes with involving
Firearms um and and they're not getting
cash bill could you describe that what
what that would look like a felony
Reckless conduct um someone fires a
firearm um at a house doesn't hit anyone
you know but it's they fired it
recklessly and it went through someone's
uh it could go through your neighbor's
you know door um you know we just had
one in gtown end of August that you know
we had uh we still still in AC of
Investigation but a house was shot shot
at
um you're not talking about though
someone recklessly target shooting
you're talking about like a driveby or
just someone you being an idiot driving
around Sho yes yep okay yeah no and
um just firing it happens and it happens
happens in Manchester all the time um
and and absence some like I said some
exceptional circumstances they're not
going to be held on cash
bail I think anyone who lives in the
sure can take a look at um any number of
street signs and see the holes and we
know that there's a little bit of recous
shooting going on so the committee will
take that um that that crime under
advisement
um with regard to
um do you see the value in making having
a judge have to take a second look at
these in other words lifting it from the
bail commissioner and and making it go
to a judge I do and I and the a a
benefit of that is that the prosecutor
will also get to go in front of the
judge and and whether that person's held
or not there they can recommend
conditions of bail to the judge whereas
you know if someone's arrested at night
uh the bail commissioner comes in uh the
the state the prosecutor they're not
going to find out about this until you
know yeah and and and if those
conditions aren't correct or there's
conditions that they would like added in
there you're looking at a couple weeks
before they're going to get a bail
hearing because that person's released
on PR so it's not a they're not going to
have a a bill hearing on that um you
know exponentially it's going to be it's
going to be some time so you could go a
couple weeks you could go a month with
you know and if there's I've seen it
happen before with there you know it's a
DV arrest but there was never checked
off the box for no
contact UM and in a lot of lot of times
we don't have a correct address where's
that person staying now that they can't
go back to where they were living with
their partner and that leads down the
you know the Court's sending them
notices but they're sending it to the
the address where he's not at and then
you're racking up failure to appear is
because they're not so there's a benefit
of going in front of the
judge not just to hold someone but to
get the correct bail conditions and have
the prosecutor have a a chance to to
weigh in on the bill conditions with the
judge thank you I'm going to have
another question but I want to kind of
set the stage for the committee
first it's my understanding the way it
works is the bail commissioner will will
set bail and there will be conditions
but when he's finished or she's finished
they they have to take a paper
form Fold It Up put an envelope put a
stamp on it and mail it to the
court so before the court even knows
this person's out on bail it could be a
week before the the document gets to the
court before the court has time to open
the envelope and enter it into a system
so you've got people floating around for
up to a week or more on bail with
conditions that only he or she and the
police that arrested them know exist so
that person goes to another town or even
perhaps another County um nobody knows
about any of this and this is why
were're taking a look at this
comprehensively instead of just saying
oh these crimes can't be what good does
that do if nobody knows about it so
um in your experience U Captain how long
does it take and and a follow on
question would be do you have the
ability to arrest based on your
knowledge of bail conditions if you see
someone violating it for example um no
no going to a bar or whatever and you
see someone blatantly violing condition
of bail that you know about personally
if you had that that knowledge you it
would even have to be firsthand
knowledge that you saw that bail you saw
that bail condition you saw the the bail
paperwork um you bring up a good point
because if someone's arrested in
gtown um for domestic violence and
they're given um conditions of bail from
the bail commissioner um and then they
go to
Manchester they go that same night the
next morning and they're in a restaurant
with that person and the police come in
contact with them unless they know to
call over to gown to check they're not
going to know that that person has
bail and does that apply to protective
orders as well I mean if someone in your
jurisdiction in golf town gets a
protective order against their spouse
and they get into a domestic altercation
in Manchester you know 3 4 days later
does the Manchester police even know
that a protective order exists if it's
in the system and I can't speak to the
for the court as to what the timeline is
or when that is entered into the system
so uh I do know in
um well it does wouldn't happen too much
but if we do if we you know gwn police
will
notify you know if the person lives in
Manchester you know we may zip like a
fax over but often times I I don't know
how quick that gets in the system well
what we know let's just talk about not
let's not talk about orders issued in
the court because that should
theoretically be in the system right
away but let's talk about emergency
orders that are issued over a weekend or
holiday or a Friday
night is there any way for another
department barring you faxing around the
state for them to know that there's a
protective
order I'm unaware of
that
that's all I had a minut representative
Stone thank you Mr chairman one of the
questions I have is that your agency
when a bail commissioner comes in do you
provide them with a probable cause
affidavit or supportive
arrest um they
will have
the by the when the bail commissioner is
there often times the the the guy is
arrested he brought in he goes into
booking the bail commit will come and
say what are the
charges but there's no report done at
that point so we we for domestic
violence they're brought in their arrest
they go into booking the officer is
there booking him or her
and they'll call the bail
commissioner while he's doing his you
know getting the fingerprints going
through the list of um you know his
background and name and running they'll
run his
um criminal record and we have a
dispatch right in our Police Department
so dispatch will run that criminal
record and give it to the officer so the
bail commissioner will really only have
and we're lucky enough to have a
dispatch in our um Police Department so
we have access to um run a criminal
record 24 hours seven days a week
there's police departments that don't
have that luxury so all the baill
commissioner is going to see is the
charges and his criminal history
follow
up in addition uh is it typical for a
bill commissioner or the officer to kind
of give a quick uh rundown of the
charges that are pending at that time he
be having Bill Set uh previous charges
or no no the current charges when
someone's arrested and they're in the
booking area and the bail commission
comes in does typically the officer of
your department that you may or may not
be aware of kind of give a synopsis of
what brought that person into
custody not all the time
um if there's extending circumstances
they made but there really only the bill
commission is only seeing the charge in
his
history so they don't give them for
example you have a domestic violence
arrest the the bill commissioner only
sees domestic violence arrest he doesn't
say you don't explain okay yeah he he
actually we saw him beating up his wife
or there's no background at all they
will give a quick background but they're
not going to have a full out G or prob
cost affidavit and you know they'll ask
for um you know what was the victim's
name should be no contact and um and and
in those questions they'll ask but
they're not um the officer hasn't even
sat at the computer yet and started
typing until usually the bail
commissioner has left and and that uh
defendant has been released and that's
assuming the officer wasn't injured
during the arrest what do you do in a
case where that happens I mean that
won't that wouldn't um you know if he's
if the officer is you know at the
hospital they not you go to you know
City's Nashville Manchester that officer
that makes the
arrest you know they may not even
transport them back to the police
department if they go in the the wagon
or they bring him to the booking they
drop them off and there's a booking
officer then will take down here's his
charges and then the bail commissioner
will come in and speak to the booking
officer who wasn't even at the
scene and it can take a while for the
officer to get have an opportunity to
write the report right if he has to go
to hospital first or it could still be
at the scene yeah yeah okay excellent
um hold on a second I had a few other
questions that this this line has
brought up um so we're we're
contemplating and we've just discussed
um possibly um if if we have this list
of crimes and the person is non-bailable
by bail commissioner and we were to
require a judge to do a hearing on on a
weekend do do you have any other
instances where you contact uh judicial
system over the weekend we do um for you
know
emergency um protective
orders uh emergency um you know search
warrants uh judges are available by
phone for those uh emergency situations
emergency arrest warrants search
warrants protective orders would you
give us just an example uh just a kind
of a rundown how that would work do you
fax them do you guys Zoom how do you do
it so we we have a would' be a would
call the on call Judge we have a list um
they the county will give us of the
judges that are on call and they'll ask
you know for instance say it's a felony
domestic violence and we need an arrest
warrant um and we can't you know you're
not going to wait because you're not
going to wait till Monday because of the
danger it poses to the victim so the the
judge will um you officer would call the
judge say this is what we
have here excuse me here she would say
you know can you either email majority
of time it's email they don't have fax
machines at their house but email or fax
me um your affidavit and warrant and
stay on the phone and the judge will
read that have any questions asked and
then you know zip it back to the officer
um electronically and now that the they
do have a new the court does have an new
electronic system of signing those but
they will call the judge to bring it to
their attention
immediately okay so the court does have
some experience with exchanging evidence
with the officers and talking to them
over the weekend sure so adding um very
serious crimes that would require them
to make a decision on bail wouldn't be
that big of a stretch or or at least not
totally alien to them I don't want to
speak for them but we do contact judges
on nights and
weekends thank you
um back to yeah how often does that
occur
roughly once a week couple times a I I
would I would say um Ju Just for go
towns yeah maybe once a week you know a
few times a month if you were to ask
aldenberg and Manchester I would say
daily okay um something else you brought
up that that's interesting in the
committee I I I know it but the
committee I think needs to know it there
are police departments and I want you to
correct my statements that in this state
that cannot sit down and run uh someone
they just arrested they cannot run their
criminal record is that is that accurate
uh I yeah I have heard that if they
don't have a Dispatch Center they don't
have um access to do that um yeah
they're not going to be able to run a
triple ey or a criminal history and do
you run a a triple ey for the committee
is a is a federal check with the FBI
that shows their record across the
country um do you run a triple I on
everyd yes okay um and you run an
Hampshire record check as well yes okay
so there are departments as best of your
knowledge um probably in more Rural and
Northern sections of the state that
don't even have a computer terminal
where they can sit down and check the
record the person they have in custody
meaning that they could potentially be a
fugitive from Justice from the state
they could be there could be any number
of things yeah that the police just
don't have access to is that accurate
yeah they they if they they have a
Dispatch Center outside Dispatch Center
like a county or and they they're
not their Dispatch Center is probably
running that for them and then they're
going to have to make their way at some
point over there to pick it up um there
are a a triple eyes you know you can't
email them there's very strict um
security measures um with the records so
I I would assume that they have to would
have to drive to that Dispatch Center
wherever it is wherever it was printed
to get it and that that may not be that
shift that may not be that day um they
may just make a trip once a week I don't
know I don't we don't but I have heard
that that if they don't have a Dispatch
Center they're they're not running it in
house and they're not going to have it
on hand and if there are many police
departments in the state that may only
have one officer on it night is that
correct a lot so you've got one officer
with somebody in
custody it's um not really reasonable to
assume he's going to be able to drive to
a Dispatch Center that maybe you know 20
miles away now go gtown police our
Dispatch Center also dispatches for New
Boston police um wear police and
Dunbarton police
um New Boston and and Dunbarton often
only have one officer on I don't think
if they have two it's during the day
because the chief is there when they
make an arrest our Dispatch Center runs
their triple ey we may not see them they
may go to their own you know they may
write you know do the booking at their
place not come and we you know we'll put
it aside for them when they come to pick
it up are you allowed to broadcast over
the radio if there's the the contents of
the triple ey to tell the officer this
is what you
got
I I don't know the par I I don't know
that um you don't hear it but I don't
know
if I don't know if that is uh breaches
any security things with there it might
I'm not sure could you check on it check
that y also what about um out of state
warrants you know you got your fugitive
from justice warrants you could have
someone you pick up who's got a warrant
out of Illinois um uh is the Dispatch
Center allowed to say that to us you're
knowledge say this guy's got uh he's
wanted from yes and that happens often
now in that case how how do you handle
fugitive from justices with regard to
the bail Commissioners in the bail
system it um it depends if it's
extraditable um you know often times
they'll have a warrant that isn't in New
England uh could be out of Texas but it
it says only surrounding states um so we
won't be able to we won't be able to
take them into custody on that if it's
one that we can take them into custody
say it's um it says you know arrestable
in New England states that's often what
you see um we'll take them into custody
uh we will hold them um contact the
agency with their warrant is out of to
see if they're going to come get them
because that's a question the judge will
ask is this agency going to come get
them because I'm not going to hold them
if they're not um so that that's the the
way we go with that um and it when the
agency says they're going to come up the
judge usually wants them within seven
days to come pick this um defending up
so for example for the committee you
could have somebody um with a warrant
out of California for failure to pay a
fine generally speaking that state is
not going to spend thousands of dollars
for several officers to fly to New
Hampshire to pick up someone who owes a
$100 fine that's I think what the what
you're trying to no they're not going to
to you we'll see it a lot a lot of time
out of New York um and you exactly or
low you know a lowlevel crime and and
they're just like we're not we're not
coming you know if they get picked up in
state they'd hold them but they're not
going to come out of state to pick that
person up do you know if New Hampshire
um as a state do we have any policy on
um people that are running around our
state with warrants out of other states
do do we anyway do anything about it or
we just let them
um it when we so say I enter a
warrant and I put it in
NCI that you have to check off do you
want this person arrested out of state
you know in how you know do you can
check off Nationwide New England or
neighboring states so if we have people
running around New Hampshire with States
from out with warrants from out of state
we can only arrest them if it says that
we're able to so for instance it's
California and it says neighboring
states we can run them he could have a
felony warrant out of California we
can't arrest them but if it says um you
know Massachusetts they get a warrant
out of Massachusetts and it says
extraditable for neighboring states we
can arrest it it depends on the issuing
agency what they do with the warrant
that will dictate how we can take them
into custody many states and correct me
again if I'm wrong have a system whereby
if you have a warrant at some point your
driver's license gets attached and you
lose your they they suspend it um if
someone's license is suspended in
California for a warrant or failure to
pay a child support or something we do
recognize that and their New Hampshire
license would also be suspended is that
is that your understanding
yes they would be you could arrest them
for you know operating without a valid
license but you you know if the unless
that charge is extraditable we can't
arrest it to that okay any other any
other questions for the captain based on
um I'm going to call him representative
scitech did you want to ask a question
or and testify a little bit
yourself
so to just to add some more to the to
the cabin's testimony if they picked up
someone from
Massachusetts which said neighboring
states they wouldn't even have to call
the bill commissioner because it's not
bailable if the charge
says that's where we go in front of the
judge and that that's the questions the
judge will ask okay I was talking about
repres thank you for question um so the
uh nonviolent crimes are down violent
crimes are up how how longer the are the
um uh defendants being held you know
during the week they're probably in and
out within 24 hours but what's your
experience with you know how long is an
average hold for a person with a charge
with a violent crime are they in and out
what how long is the told that's getting
PR bailed or that's going in front of a
judge so so somebody gets arrested for
um carjacking with a weapon or
whatever that you get arrested uh
charged with a violent crime with a
weapon and it's a Friday how long is is
that person held are they just are you
talking about they're not making bail
they're not getting PR bail they're
going to go in front of a judge could so
there's no way they can get bail so if
they don't go okay so so if they get
arrested Friday they would be um
arraigned the next court day Monday so
is that common I mean do you see most
people held greater than 24 hours or are
most people released within 24 hours is
the 24hour hold or greater common
place they're usually released that next
court date so it it would be less than
24 hours if they were arrested on a
Thursday night but if they're arrested
on a Friday they're going it could be
Monday or Tuesday depending on if it's a
holiday but they will get the next court
date right right okay thank you and just
I think what the representative was
asking is violent crimes that are the
decision is made either by the bail
commissioner or by Statute that they're
not bailable over the weekend how how
often did you see that um in other words
how often do you have to feed people
over a whole weekend yeah in that that
would be a a great question for uh the
county jails um because we won't hold
them we'll we'll bring them to the
county jail um but I can speak for gos
town we don't often have anyone that
gets held um they're all usually PR bail
I I would assume the city would have a
lot more um that are being held but I
don't know what the numbers are on
that so it's really a demographic issue
the wherever you have more violent crime
you're more likely to have people held
at what time in the process that someone
is is being held does does they do they
get transferred to the county
jail we if they're being held we we'll
have them at the county jail within an
hour or two they're only going to be at
the Golf Town Police Department enough
to get the booking procedure done and
then we're going to drive them over to
Valley Street jail in Manchester within
I'd say an hour maybe two
Max thank you any representative Pratt
you mentioned that they would be um go
to court the next court day are there
holidays for the
court the court does have holidays yes
the so it might not be Monday no it
could be Tuesday if there is a Monday
holiday okay that's it thank you
yeah um back to the the technology just
real quick does and I'll ask you to put
on your Chiefs of police I know that
you're just kind of loosely representing
him today but do you see value in
ensuring that every Police Department in
the state has a connection to check
records in want and warrant yes it would
be
um it it's really really helpful to have
a cross agency check and that is not
running a a criminal record but you
could run you know we have an internal
system so if they're in gown we run them
we may see that oh they were just
arrested last night um or we were just
there for um a domestic situation where
there was an arrest but I can see that
there was a report from yesterday
Manchester won't see that because it's
only in our system nsha State Police
they won't see that because it's only in
our system if there was a way to cross
agency check everything that would be
extremely
helpful and if you know um just for the
committee correct me if I'm wrong most
of our surrounding states have this and
have had it for decades is is that not
your understanding as well I I can't
speak to that I don't know that's fine
um
is there anything else you'd like the
committee to know while you're
here no okay any further questions
before we let know no thank you for your
testimony this morning thank
you I just have a comment for you Mr
chair if I could yes go ahead so I'm
just wondering if before we make a firm
decision on what in this list we include
if we could hear from the public
defenders and victims first just so we
make it clear what the effects of a
crime like stalking even if it is a
misdemeanor or something or the other
would be on somebody uh whether they're
being charged with it or if it's a
victim of one of those crimes yeah
that's that's um that is my intent I
have invited the um domestic violence
Coalition and the public defender office
to come in um it's my intent that we
don't vote on anything firmly until
we're just about finished um we're going
to have informal votes so we kind of
don't have any surprises when we start
putting this package together um so uh I
want to have every possible bit of
knowledge that we can get before we make
a final vote on anything I appreciate
that but I think the committee um some
of us may be shocked by the fact that
where we are technology-wise in this
state we make a lot of assumptions based
on what we watch on TV and you some of
us sadly aren't shocked but um it it's
not that way um it should be but it's
not um you know you see on television
someone getting picked up and they're in
their car doing a quick and they know
the guy's you know credit history here
our officers are asked to and our bail
Commissioners frankly to make
decisions based on no information and
other that's what sits in front of them
right then and whether or not that's
true um you know that's anyone's guess
they ask are you out on bail well maybe
the guy will say yes and maybe he won't
um we heard before from the state police
that they would often find out someone
was on bail because when they were
arrested and inventory of the car they
found bail slips in the in the in the
car so um I don't think that's a way to
run a criminal justice system and I hope
everyone agrees um representative GA
representative GA please B
me officer would you mind taking the um
one more time for a moment and I saw you
uh Professor sheer would you mind we
just have one more question for
you
thank you for taking my question I you
know I just want to make sure that I
truly understand stood what you said
when you talked in terms of you have
access to a judge um under certain
circumstances is that correct that's
correct okay so if someone's arrested
and the bail people Commissioners say um
we're going to bail them but you don't
feel they should be bailed you can call
on call judge no we canot call Judge for
that okay so if it's a bail issue you
can't no but anything else you could not
anything else it's it's really strictly
for emergency situations where warrants
warrants search warrants arrest warrants
emergency protection orders okay thank
you very
much along that that just gave me um an
idea also would there be any value in
giving the police the opportunity to
appeal a bail commissioner's decision if
say um on a Thursday somebody was
arrested no make it a Friday someone's
arrested the bail commissioner say I
think I'm going to let him go and based
on your experience with this particular
individual that the bail commissioner
might not be aware of or the background
situation you think you know gez I'm
just not going to feel good tonight
letting this guy go would there be any
value in allowing you to appeal it to a
judge there there would be because the
only Avenue that we would have at that
point the state would have is the bail
commissioner leasum you know prosecutor
police don't you know they have some
circumstance they don't believe that
we'd have to file a motion to have a
bail hearing and it could be a week it
could be two weeks it could be three
weeks that it gets scheduled because the
priority isn't for um non-incarcerated
um defendants if he's not incarcerated
the court is not going to schedule that
the next day that's the only way they're
going to schedule the next day if he's
incarcerated so if he's not incarcerated
you're looking at weeks before you get
in front of there to address your
concern so he's he or she is out for a
couple weeks it could be three it could
be almost a month at some points if the
judge if there's no judge time or that
you know you're in a court that you know
doesn't have a judge every day and
that's kind of gambling because you know
either he's going to do something or
he's not in that time period right right
um okay often times when we see uh bail
being violated it's
fairly um close to the time that they're
released
the the time right after a domestic a
time you know that they're
usually um it's those days after it that
that we see that they're violating the
contact thank you any other
questions okay thank you um Professor
Sher thank thank you I'll be uh really
brief uh one uh I was just talking to uh
one of the baill Commissioners uh they
don't put the court order in the the the
bail order in the mail what happens is
once the bail order gets signed they fax
it to the court um so it's it's not as
uh it there's it's not as long a period
between the time the bail order is
issued by the bail commissioner and the
time it gets the cour court it's my
understanding I had heard that um some
bail Commissioners don't have fax
machines um so yeah um and and and maybe
I'll hear for some I'll hear from the
bail commission
um the the hard topic is domestic
violence issue and bail and and you know
I fully appreciate having known
personally people who've been victims of
domestic violence uh about what I would
call the scorge of domestic
violence um
as with
addiction um and mental health issues
it's really dangerous to try and use the
bail system not the whole criminal legal
system but the bail system to sort out
too much about domestic violence um the
perfect example is this whether um
whether you hold a person even on a
misdemeanor domestic violence uh for up
to 24 hours or you hold them for 4 days
uh my understanding in talking to any
number of people they're not going to be
any more cooled down uh when they get
out of jail after that hold than they
would be if they get out on PR bail um
and you
know it that's easy for me to say I
think it's actually quite true but I
don't know what the answer is um but uh
I just
caution the committee
in feeling they can address the issue of
people who are charged with domestic
violence and once they get out either
immediately on PR Baal or 24 hours later
uh after seeing a judge or four days
later um uh that the likelihood of them
violating a protective order or going
back uh to where they were and and uh um
becoming involved in negative ways with
uh uh the the victim um it's still
pretty high
so um I don't have a neat and tidy
answer you know the the neat and tidy
answer is one that we can't do it's like
we can't hold everybody who's charged
with misdemeanor or felony domestic
violence until they have a trial you
know I me that's not realistic uh I
don't I wish I could offer the committee
an answer but I I caution you uh about
thinking
that the bail system as it is or making
changes in the bail system is going to
deal in a in a realistic way with the
substance of this problem that's a
depressing thing to say but um uh last
um oh second to last
uh the difference between calling up a
judge and getting a search warrant or
going to a judge's house knocking on the
door at 6:00 in the morning after
alerting the judge and getting the judge
to sign a search warrant because you
need it on the weekend uh and uh having
a bail hearing is at a bail hearing
you're going to need to have
counsel um and and uh uh with all that
comes with a you know particularly if
it's a bail hearing where you're looking
to detain somebody without bail you're
going to have to have you it's a
significant event that can't be done in
the same way that uh getting a search
warrant sign can be done that said yes
judges sometimes do weekend Duty you
know I I've talked to judges who
particularly in more busy uh areas
counties in the state where they they
frequently are signing warrant the
police are coming to their house to get
them to sign a warrant or
uh more in so-called modern times um
significantly after I finished
practicing um they can do it
electronically but um it's uh judges
work on the
weekends but they haven't been doing
things as significant as bail
hearings uh quick question before you go
to your next um from a constitutional
perspective if if someone's arrested and
you have a bail
commissioner um making a decision with
in a non-adversarial uh
type of situation why could a judge not
do the same thing in in replace assume
we had no bail Commissioners and only
judges made that quick decision
regarding bail why would you need to
have a full hearing with a full panoply
of of all the the
actors and and make it an adversarial
versus where the commissioner does is it
just by virtue of their office uh no I
no um
when you're seeing a
judge about bail the judge is setting
bail for the entire time up to the trial
occurring so potentially somebody can be
held if if if they're seeking to hold
somebody without bail um uh the
significance of how long somebody can be
held the the significance of the dep the
extent of the deprivation of Liberty is
such that you're entitled to to that
array of due process rights clear and
convincing evidence standard uh counsel
the right to call witnesses to cross
examine you know that's that's
constitutionally a case called us versus
solo has laid that down when somebody is
seeing a bail commissioner who has the
power to detain somebody without
bail but even under the system as it is
it can't be any longer than you know
right now the system can be as long as 4
days uh um that's a shorter period of
time the long you know the the extent to
which you get Beyond 4 days you start to
run into constitutional uh problems the
the extent to which the deprivation of
Liberty gets longer than that
constitutionally you start to run into
let's call them solerno problems um so a
bail commissioner is only deciding to
hold them until they see a judge uh a
judge is deciding to hold them
until trial a big difference between
deprivation of Liberty and those two
could we not craft a statute that said a
judge on a weekend hearing can only
decide and this would be a dangerousness
Flight Risk hearing or decision only
until the next court business day where
they would be entitled to their full
solo hearing
uh to be a little too cute I don't want
you to tell me if the court would like
that or not I just no no no no I'm not
going to say that's essentially what the
system is
now but we have a a Commissioners doing
it and holding them till they can get to
court changing it to a judge to hold
them until they get to court uh six to
one half dozen of the other it it's the
same
thing
um what was your next
Point um
actually I'm sorry I didn't see you and
Stu thank you Mr chair I guess my
question to you is do you think it would
be beneficial for more information to be
available to a bill
commissioner with the facts and
circumstances of individual cases when
it comes to weighing out Public Safety
versus
Liberty you know I I think it depends on
the uh uh the jurisdiction the chief you
heard from is is
gtwn um uh you know I
think it varies tremendously from Police
Department to police department and bail
commissioner and at how much information
they have you know sometimes the police
are arresting somebody who they know you
know and it's not unusual and and they
have tons of information you know that's
the ca I know that's very frequently the
case in Portsmouth um um other times in
the bigger police departments they have
easy access to more information
I don't uh
um it's always good for anyone who's
making a decision about depriving
somebody of their Liberty to have as
much information or and prot making a
decision whether to deprive someone of
Liberty and protect their Public Safety
or not to have as much information as
possible um uh I think as the chair has
made clear you know I too am a very
strong advocate of improving the
communication and the access to
information uh in the state because I
think that'll make a big difference for
everybody thank
you again from a from a constitutional
perspective is there less of an issue
with
including um domestic violence uh in a
list of crimes like this if we're only
talking about 24 hours or less to hear
to to see a judge versus more than 24
hours or are there other reasons why um
from a constitutional perspective it's a
good idea to to not include a crime like
that in this
list I think if somebody who ail who is
included on this list and therefore
doesn't see a bail commissioner and they
wait to to see a judge um I think yes uh
I would have
some different feelings about what's on
the list now as to domestic violence you
know I go back to what I said earlier if
if you hold somebody uh for uh 24 hours
who's charged with even a misdemeanor
domestic violence yeah I just don't in
terms of them going back and and causing
trouble with their victim uh I just
don't think holding them for 24 hours is
really going to change that so domestic
violence is
a it's just a difficult problem and it's
really hard to use the it's even harder
to use the bill system to make any
progress in solving the problem with
domestic violence crimes than it is with
addiction or mental health it's just a
really hard problem that said a separate
issue issue with
including misdemeanors at all on this
list is it means there's going to be a
heck of a lot more hearings on Saturday
and Sunday and I think you've heard from
the court system before on the the list
that was in uh Senator susi's Bill has
been in Senator Bradley's bill in the
past that most comprehensive list uh
would involve 3 to 4,000 more hearings
than there would otherwise be because it
has misdemeanors on it so put us it's an
odd thing to say but putting aside the
Constitutional issues there's a real
Court expense to having misdemeanors on
that list rather than just having
felonies and and it's a balancing you
know it's not there's not a nice simple
answer um you know I the last just
transition to the last thing I want to
say is I'm an advocate for having
felonious stalking felonious uh domestic
violence on the list um uh and uh
because you know those are particularly
serious domestic violence related crimes
not to suggest that other misdemeanor
domestic violence isn't serious but in
terms of you know at least a 24-hour
hold if we have a system where there's
they're going to see in 24 hours I think
that's really important um uh you
know um so uh that's what that's what I
advocate I understand there's different
views on that but I I I I think the the
committee is is really beginning to
understand there's not a neat and tidy
answer to this that it involves a
balancing of court costs it involves a
balancing of constitutional rights it
involves a balancing of Public Safety
um and
yeah that's why you all get the big
box yeah when it when it comes
to one of the things um an impression I
I get every time I hear testimony from
Bill Commissioners is that there do seem
to be a different set of personal
standards that people use in in making
these decisions so if we don't put
something like misdemeanor domestic
violence you know on this list then
basically it would go back and be
something where we would be really
dependent on bail Commissioners to make
a really good decision so with that in
mind should we do something like that do
you think part of whatever we wind up
proposing uh should include um training
and perhaps mandatory training for bail
Commissioners specifically in these in
areas things that maybe on this list now
that might not wind up being on the
final list or some of the things that we
we've actually already talked about one
crime that's not on the list that maybe
should be uh I'm I'm I'm always an
advocate of uh training not only for
bail Commissioners but for judges you
know if I were I will be very blunt with
the committee on domestic violence
crimes I don't think
judges make any better set of decisions
as to bail on domestic violence crimes
than bail Commissioners do you know so I
think it's training across the board and
and and I know uh the uh spiran district
courts have made aggressive efforts to
do better training um
um
again I I hate to be so end on such a
Negative note the problem of domestic
violence in the criminal justice system
is a big one and uh it's really hard to
manage it's and the bail is
just there's not that much other than
holding anyone charged with domestic
violence until they see
trial um there's no easy solution and
you know for the reasons I've described
it's just really hard problem I hate
to I hate to be so negative but that's
what I've seen over 40 years thank you
thank you for your testimony
Professor um hold on
um we've heard uh we've heard quite a
bit of testimony um and my intent is um
we're going to take a probably a
15minute vir break in a minute and when
I come back we've heard a lot of
testimony and we've we've mostly been
talking about bail Commissioners um and
and right in front of their faces so
we're going to let them talk to us when
we come back I want to hear from the
bail Commissioners all including um
representative scitec if you'd like to
add something real quick right now this
would be very quick I yearned to say
many things but let me stick to one fact
there was
almost horror talked about because the
papers are so long getting to the court
the bail commissioner's handbook written
by the judicial branch gives bail
Commissioners two two days to get the
papers back to the court that's the fact
are you aware of how long it takes the
court to get them entered into the
system so that everyone else knows about
them I have no idea but I wholeheartedly
support your idea of Greater and
everybody's idea of Greater
communication that baale in Manchester
should be known throughout the state but
that's I that's in a different I'm
talking Beyond
facts um representative did you want to
add something yes I did Mr chairman
thank you so we came here last week and
we heard a lot of testimony we are we're
sitting here again this morning and
we're hearing a lot of
testimony and the one thing that I think
that we as a committee understand
is the victims of these crimes should
never under any circumstances be blamed
for being the victim of a
crime
and I can appreciate the testimony we're
hearing but I also know that when you
have a domestic violence
victim these human beings are either
being beaten
or they're just being degraded into
submission so maybe holding them for 24
hours
doesn't give the perpetrator a cool down
period but what it does
do it gives that victim and those
children a chance to get to a safe house
it gives them a chance to get some funds
and get away and I think that we need to
get back to focus on the victims of
these
crimes not protecting the perpetrator
and finding an
excuse I I wholeheartedly agree except
for a very small alleged perpetrator and
we always have to keep that in mind even
even even though it hurts I I agree that
um that period of time does does give uh
the victims a chance to collect
themselves and and get some protection
but we always have to keep in mind it's
aend as much as we know it may be not be
in and however we feel personally but I
I wholeheartedly agree that a certain
period of time isn't necessarily only
for the defendant um to cool down but
also exactly to your point for the
victim to um to get themselves someplace
safe and the help they need for them fam
and their children um with that being
said we're going to take a um 15 did you
have I represent did you need to add
something you we're going to take a
15minute break um so we'll be back here
at um 20 let's just break until 20 till
at which time I'm going to ask the bail
Commissioners to um address us and maybe
take some questions and then we'll end
the day with um some discussion on the
committee about everything we've heard
is everybody okay with that okay we will
be um breaking for 15
minutes
e
and we are back I apologize for the
delay but fortuitously I ran into into
one of the finance chairman um because
we have been talking about spending a
lot of money in here and um he is going
to come next Thursday represent wer and
we're going to pitch Loosely some of the
ideas we have and uh he's going to tell
us whether or not um there's even money
for it before we get too far down the
street and then we'll have them come
back again when we have some more hard
numbers for him so I think that that's a
good start as far as making sure we're
not contemplating Pie in the Sky
um and um I don't have any control over
that so at this point I would really
like to hear from the bail commissioners
um I'll start um with um Mr far you you
you are no longer officially a bail
commissioner but you have more years
doing it than most of us have um on this
committee or any other so we'll start
with you and then we'll move down to
whoever who else would like to
testify for the record I do not believe
representative scitec will be testifying
he's more of a uh more of a source for
us to tap when we're in our discussions
um and we will certainly be utilizing
him so with that I give you the floor
thank you my name is Trixie lefave I had
been a bail commissioner for 14 years
and resigned effective August 31st of
this year committee is on the right
track and I really appreciate that some
of the things that I heard this morning
though that I just wanted
to um clarify from my experience I can
only speak to my experience but um it
was mentioned that we possibly as a bail
commissioner when we're meeting with a
defendant do not have access access to
their criminal history in the smaller
departments especially because they
don't have a dispatcher I do know that
when I was working for the Derry Circuit
Court uh if I would respond to Sandown
or Chester the sheriff's department was
responsible for getting the criminal
history to the police department via
fact and then I would review it never
should a bail commissioner and I did not
but never should a bail commissioner
process an individual without having the
criminal history in front of them it's
absolutely Ely important on that same
note there is also information if there
are restraining orders against this
particular person that we're processing
um which then takes me over to the
criminal bail protective order um those
are sent up to New Hampshire State
Police immediately when I worked for
Manchester and it's in the bail
commissioner's handbook that we must
send it up to them immediately that's
facts from the Manchester Police
Department so the state of New Hampshire
every law enforcement agency should be
aware of that within a half hour of our
booking and processing the individual I
should say uh because it's in the
system with regard to what you're
thinking with your charges that um an
individual would not see a bail
commissioner you speak of domestic
violence I'm not pitching one way or
another What charges would not be seen
by a bail commissioner and what would go
to a judge I just want this committee to
understand that
when a person has been charged with
domestic violence you have a victim if
they do not see a bail commissioner or
if they are not processed immediately
but taken to a county jail and held
whether it's for 24 hours or 48 hours
there is no order of protection for that
victim so that that alleged perpetrator
could reach out to that victim from jail
to continue with acts of intimidation
could call a friend to have acts of
intimidation so when this committee
makes that decision Please be aware that
there has there should be an order of
protection for that victim immediately
when the decision is made whether this
defendant is going to go to jail or be
seen by a bail commissioner may I just
interrup I don't want to interrupt but I
have to I I need to know so is it
possible though for for example say um
the police arrest someone on domestic
violence charge and it's one that in the
contemplated would not be um bailable by
a bail commissioner can they not call
the judge to get an emergency
order they can call for an emergency
order
but the emergency order is and you know
have to I'm not I'm not part of that
process with an emergency order I hadn't
been I should
say I am assuming that the answer to
that is yes um but the alleged
perpetrator is not being charged with
any well is not being processed for the
crimes so the bail order or the bail
process would take place days later so I
guess there you would need to seek
clarification on that so there's two
tracks there's the bail conditions which
would set no contact with the victim Etc
which you are saying if we didn't have a
bail commissioner and they get sent to
Valley Street they could contact because
there's no bail conditions on the
alternative though the judge an
emergency order could be issued as far
as you know that would do the same thing
it just would require the judge correct
and that would mean possibly for the
committee two calls to a judge one for
the emergency order and then within 24
hours another for the whether or not to
hold or let them go for the actual
arraignment okay please continue re and
I apologize that's thank you um and my
final note is um as you are joining
other members of the um of this Pro of
the process of defendants is um you know
processing defendants there are are
times when these individuals are on
probation or parole and that you should
be able to pick up in the criminal order
that you're looking at you know their
the criminal history I have to tell you
that in my 14 years of trying to contact
probation of parole officer to determine
if they want a 72-hour hold um probably
1% of the time and it could be a Friday
afternoon and I have someone in front of
me and trying to reach their parole
officer or their probation offer office
to determine what they want to do um is
darn near impossible so I think that as
you look at all of this as well you need
to pull into the the grand scheme of
things the probation of parole should be
as accessible as the judges are after
hours thank you actually I was
contemplating um this I know that in in
Massachusetts and I hate to use them as
an example but um some things they have
right if if someone even if a police
department even runs a record check on
one of their parole e the system
automatically pings that parole officer
and says someone's run your guy which
point it triggers him to call the police
and say why'd you run my guy if he's
violating his Pearl at that point so I I
think you're you're absolutely on the
Mark we need to make sure we tie in all
these and even if it's only an
electronic notification that their
person has been held they get it on the
weekend and whatever time of night it is
they they get notified because I know
parole officers I I believe are you know
technically 24 hours a day they're
supposed to be um on the job so to speak
um that is what we are told so we have
never seen that as a practice but that
is what we are told indeed
representative go ahead thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I I would like to clarify
something we had heard that that bill
Commissioners have is it 48 hours I
believe to get to get the bail order to
the
court and we're talking about having an
electronic system you know we're kind of
stuck in the 70s 80s over here in New
Hampshire so would it be helpful or did
the bail Commissioners have access to I
I know I used to use a online it was
called doc you sign and the document the
legal documents were already uploaded
into that you you know kind of filled it
out and sent to the person and it kind
of walks them right through so would
that be helpful if the bail
Commissioners had access to something
like that and then they literally could
just hit the submit button and go right
to the court instead of having to wait
for it to kind of wander around and
snail mail I'm sure that that would be
very helpful um but I do know that when
we were just as a aside as when we were
talking during coid of doing telephonic
bailes there were areas of the North
Country especially over in the ACP area
that they did not have good service good
internet service so that was a
consideration and then you also then are
requiring every bail commissioner to
have access to a fax machine or if even
if it's um a scanner to scan an email so
that would be something that every bail
commissioner would have to consider when
they were taking their appointment and
and which phrases it would be it would
automatically be in the system they just
hit the button have access to the
internet if they had a button um which
brings is
that okay
um I have a this brings a what what kind
of equipment U are you are you issued
are you issued anything or oh no we're
not issued anything no our equipment is
pen and paper so if if every bail
commissioner were were issued a a laptop
with a cell card
um would that not and access to criminal
records themselves would that not make
sense well um I may I answer something
I'm I'd like to go to First subject then
answer your question is um we during
coid we were told tele Bales so we could
do those um during during my period of
time with Manchester Police Department
in order to uh I did try to do some
telephonic bailing through them um I was
told that I could not get a criminal
history because it was coming to a
personal email and it has to go to
a.gov I brought this subject up to the
administrative office of the courts on
three separate occasions and I have
still not received a response from them
so that being said a desktop I'm sure
but you may possibly if we can't get an
answer from Judiciary in terms of if a
personal email can get a criminal
background then you may have to issue
Dogo addresses to all of your bail
Commissioners to bypass that problem if
you want to get into tele bailing well
that more importantly I think what I'm
what I'm contemplating is why would a
bail commissioner who has by law the
right to see criminal record information
not have direct access to criminal
offend record information so if you got
a call you got to come bail um Joe Smith
and you before you even got there could
call up Joe Smith's record and and know
you know this is what I doesn't make any
sense that you are allowed to have it
but you can't have it unless I show it
to you it does it seems we're
hamstringing our own our own system yeah
um any any questions for Miss
LEF is there anything else you wanted to
add uh no I know I think I've covered
what I needed to cover so thank you very
much I appreciate it thank you um next I
don't know your name so I'm just going
to say Madam bail commissioner until you
tell us who you
are uh my name is Judy cook I bail out
of Milford District Court I've been a
bail commissioner since
1998 and I have gone through more
iterations of being a bail commissioner
than probably anyone else it's still a
bail
commissioner what and by that you mean
the laws have changed so many
times um couple things um I have a
suggestion to make to your
committee um there is a website called
New Hampshire judicial branch and then
bail commissioner
forms
and I think you would understand this
process a lot better if you went on that
website and
downloaded the major forms that we use
which are the circuit and Superior Court
bail
orders um the cpb which is the criminal
bail protective order uh the what you
need to know form the request for an
attorney form those uh and there's also
the bond form those are the ones that we
use there's a few others in there that
are kind of obsolete at this point
because you will then
understand what we fill out and what
information we have to get to fill these
forms
out um I've been doing telephonic baales
since the beginning of coid and it
became very clear to me that the police
departments had no idea of what
information the bail Commissioners
needed so I developed this little
two-page form that when they email me
well first they call me and wake me up
at like 3 in the morning and then I ask
them to email me give them my email
address with their arrest
form so when I get
that I send them a copy of this with the
note any information that is not
contained on your arrest
form please fill it out or just put it
in an email very simple I said the most
important thing is is if it's District
Court I need your court date because I
don't have court dates for the whole
state of New Hampshire I do for Superior
Courts but not district
courts
so that's kind of number one I think you
will understand a lot more and once you
read over because you seem to be focused
in right now on domestic
violence once you look at the criminal
bail protective order you will perhaps
understand better how the whole system
works we fill out there's like a heading
which is filled out by the court there's
the whole rest of the form which is a
four-page form that we fill out now if
I'm doing it tell telephonically all
these forms are available in PDF
fillable forms so I will just sit down
and I will fill them out as I
go
um even if I'm at the police station
sometimes and nobody's using the
computer I'll do it that way because
they can read the forms better than
trying to read my handwriting at 3:00
a.m.
okay
um
the only other question I or answer I
would like to give you on the domestic
violence
issue is I'm really not
sure how
much more a judge is going to be able to
do
with with the perpetrator of domestic
violence than I can do because a it's
going to be a longer period of time as
Trixie
said and B when I when I see and I see
domestic violence all the time in my
work as a bail
commissioner I make absolutely sure that
they understand that if they transgress
any of any of the things and I read
every single bit of each form to them
because half the time alcohol plays a
big role and I'm really not sure that
they're going to be able to read this
and I stress the points about no
communication and all the different ways
they are not going to
communicate and then at the end I tell
them if you find it necessary to go back
to that
residence because your car is there or
your clothing is there or your dog is
there
whatever you ask the police police
officer to accompany you and that is the
only time that you were going to go back
to that residence until you are seen in
court and the court trial whatever is
finished and I I don't know that too
many of mine have transgressed that I've
never heard back from the court that you
know and I I kind of keep an eye on my
court um especially the one that's my
home
court but you know I mean i' I I had one
in Hudson one time when I was bailing
over there and it was this kid and
he' his girlfriend told him bye-bye and
so he threw her into the bathroom and
nailed the door
shut okay so she's yelling out the
window the police come they release her
they bring him to be
bailed I at that point in time it was um
bail
reform and no cash bail because we were
actually told that about five or six
years ago when that started okay so I
couldn't give him a cash
bail and I wasn't going to detain
him so I gave him the paperwork I pr him
gave him the
paperwork he went right out the door
depositing my paperwork in the circular
file on his way out went back to the
apartment grabbed her again because she
hadn't
left and tried to do the same thing
again now the police were on to him they
followed him back there he didn't even
get so far as
to enter the apartment and
they arrested him again for I guess
stalking was the crime that time and so
I asked him I
said why did you throw the paperwork
work in the in the trash as you were
leaving the the police station he said
oh well I wasn't going to go to court
anyway I mean you can't tell me what to
do you're never going to be a judge
isn't going to be able to tell that
person
anything you know and I don't really see
the difference between what bail
Commissioners do now and what judges do
except that we do it quicker because
we're 247
365 and if you rely on court time from
8:00 a.m. to
4: what are you going to do with all the
rest of that I have two towns in Milford
District Court area that when I go to
bail people there there is a
bench in the chief's office there is a
radiator with a steam pipe and the the
defendant is Shackled to the to the
steam pipe and you know I have to bail
him that way they usually do it with his
non-dominant hands so he can sign the
paperwork but I mean they're lucky they
have a computer in that police station
and if you look at the sort of Kinds Of
Towns New Hampshire has especially up
north you're you're lucky to have a room
for the police
station much
less sell holding cells booking areas I
mean those are things that
medium sized towns sometimes don't even
have you know my town I live in Brooklyn
and and my town only got a police
station
probably maybe 15 years
ago and it's been revised since
then but I I think you know you have to
understand what what we do because I
really I think only Mr Psyduck really
knows what we do the these aren't those
p p papers but it would might be helpful
for us to see your what you made if if
you if you want to share it you don't
have to no it's fine um I'll bring it up
when I'm you can just hand it to Mr
s you know I keep track I keep good
track of my bails whether I who I bail
whether I'm paid what courts they go to
and right now now
um I do a I do a lot of telephonic
bailes because I'm willing to do that
and I'm
running less than 50% on fees
collected because of the telephonic
bails I don't want to take square or any
of those other electronic means of
getting cash from people because all
they have to do is they walk out the
door and they can cancel that
so I would rather and we were told
probably before coid uh judge king sort
of told us that we
would
um if if we noted on our bail paperwork
that we weren't paid that the courts
would try to collect that for
us and they've been very good about
doing that
um but I have to
I have to make a a big asterisk on the
part because they they've put another
little line there that says bail fee $40
paid unpaid other
arrangements and then I write in there
you know pay at
court and I've been collecting because
of doing that but Milford district court
has always done that they've always been
very good about collecting but out of my
22 Superior Court bails I've done this
year only one has
paid which I find very
disappointing you um you you said you
were less than 50% total is is that
total so Milford Court's good but some
of the others not so much I'm talking
about circuit core level right
um Portsmouth has been pretty good
Manchester's starting to get
good
um Dover I've had money from
them um but other than the Milford
district court
and I usually don't do
gtown or miramac which are in that
circuit um because they have bail
Commissioners right now I'm 77 years old
and it's me and Dick cave who's 90 and
we are the two bail Commissioners in
Milford district court and Dick can't
drive drive at night
so guess
who you know but I I it it's not only
that it's very unattractive to try to
recruit people to be bail Commissioners
when they find out you get paid about
50% of the
time and you have a limited supply of
people because people with full-time
jobs aren't going to want to do this
because they don't want to be up all
night and they have a job during the day
so you're going to
have
retirees people that are self-employed
that have the kind of self-employed jobs
that they can run off and be a fireman
or a
whatever you know it's a volunteer job
sort of just like your jobs but our jobs
involve a lot more
travel um you know I spent one whole day
I did a a good thing and you know how
good things are they always come back to
bite
you I got two calls from Manchester one
night around 3 in the morning that they
had an arreste that had cash bail on an
electronic bench warrant and they
couldn't find a bail commissioner and
they needed a bail commissioner to go
pick up that
money okay so finally the second time
they called I said all right I will
drive up to Manchester and I will bail
this guy I get up there he has three
Cash Bales out of North
Hillsboro out of miramac which is
conquered and one out of um it was
supposed on the on the electronic bench
warrant we get which are very hard to
read to begin with it said it was out of
Auburn so there's no Auburn district
court now it's
Candia okay so I go to
Candia and The woman there the clerk she
says oh well we're only doing civil
cases now you'll have to go to
Dairy so I truck myself down to
Dairy and they don't want to take the
money because it's
says Auburn which is now Candia and I
said but the clerk in Candia told me to
give it to you so finally she took the
money but you know it's like that was a
whole day my whole Monday was totally
shot trying to get rid of $1,200 worth
of there were two 500s and a
200 you know I mean it's not like we're
having
fun and I don't know any Veil
commissioner that hasn't been
trained um
I mean we get trained once a year at
court that's kind of like a catchup they
now require people to Shadow another
bail commissioner for a certain amount
of
time um when I started this I was just
sort of
handed my predecessor's bail bag with
some forms in it and a few of their bail
forms that they' filled out and said do
it you know and I had to kind of self
Trin Myself by talking to the police
departments and talking to the court so
you know you guys are the ones that are
making the rules we're the ones that are
following them and I don't know anybody
that's not following them and not only
because
of I fax
everything and not only do I fax it
because I'm I'm never sure of the facts
okay I stick it in the mail too so
they're going to get two copies of
everything that I
do so you know I don't know how much how
much better we could be doing it um on
the criminal bail protective order Karen
Gorman from Superior Court she did a
whole training
session in each of the Superior Courts
for those catchman areas around them um
all about that so I I just don't know
what more can be done done if I could um
I know in previous legislatures um the
bail Commissioners have have come under
attack and I feel like um a little bit
of your testimony is defensive and it
needn't be because I don't believe
anyone in this committee blames Bill
Commissioners or what's going on here
you are doing what we told you to do we
just don't think what we told you to do
was the right the right way to do it so
we want your input so that this time
it's done right and we understand so I
appreciate you you pointing us to those
forms and we make your job easier and
not harder um at at the same time as we
take into account the whole the whole
system globally um because it's not just
B Commissioners to your point it's the
courts it's probation it's parole it's
police it's we're dealing with u it's
defense Council we're dealing and and
also very importantly it's the defendant
um in in victims so there's so many
aspects to this which is why this time
we decided we were going to look at it
holistically instead of trying to patch
all these little leaks we're going to
fix it and and so I appreciate it I just
don't want you to feel or any other Bill
commissioner to feel like this committee
feels like any of this is the bill
commissioner's fault at all I I just
want to leave you with one thought that
I've come to this conclusion over years
of doing
this and it it happened when bail reform
first started to come into New
Hampshire and I thought to myself
because I'm I'm a child of my father
being in the military and moving every
two years so I've lived everywhere in
this
country
and the south is not noted for its
fairness shall we say in judicial kinds
of
things the north has been a lot more
kind I think over the
years but I think new Hampshire when
they brought in the bail reform they
were fixing a problem that we didn't
have we might have had one or two
examples of the problem but it wasn't a
widespread thing that was polluting our
state and all it did
was um create a problem that we didn't
have and I really don't want your
committee to be creating problem s that
we don't have and solving them with
things that only become
problems because I think an example of
that was felony first which they are now
getting rid of in
January that was a problem that didn't
need fixing and it got fixed in a way
that it only caused more confusion and
now they're going to throw it
out you know so I just think think hard
about what you're you're doing because
the ramifications of it
are any change little change that gets
made is a ramification that can grow
into a big
problem and I I appreciate that and I
think every member of this committee
does as well we understand that ripples
in that pond um I believe we have a
question before you just really quickly
I don't have a question just a comment
for you miss cook I just wanted to say
thank you for your testimony and your
experience and your wisdom and bringing
it before our committee I really
appreciate you and your time that you
have spent being a bail commissioner
here in our state it's a volunteer role
more so than what we do here I mean all
we do here is sit at a table and ask
questions you're on the ground actually
doing the work and I really appreciate
you doing that so I just wanted to say
thank you but don't forget you might be
volunteers that are sitting at the table
asking questions but the outcome of what
you do is what affects everybody in this
state because it will somehow become a
rule or an RSA or something that is
going to
cause a trickle down
effect and it'll land in my lap and we
appreciate that thank you very much for
your testimony yeah yes uh go
ahead thank you for taking my question
you touched on something that I wanted
to ask and clarify is there any
direction given by either judicial
branch or by the district court that you
work for involving uh parameters of
which you set bail on somebody who is
intoxicated with either drugs or and or
alcohol like what we do with them how we
bail them like if somebody's picked up
and they're determined to be say DWI and
it's a uh say a Class A misdemeanor is
there a level of intoxication that you
will not set bail on and they need to go
sober up before you'll set bail or do
you just set bail right out of the
gate well I have to set bail that's why
I've been called to the police police
department but usually on on arrests
like
that they the police department has
already um made sure that whoever's
coming to pick them up a isn't
intoxicated themselves has a valid
license so when I when I set the bail
for that person they are given a time
under the other section as to when
they're a able to drive again and
depending on how intoxicated they are
and what what I because I always ask the
police department because they see these
people a lot more than I
do um what their recommendation is and
it's either 12 hours or 24 hours before
they're allowed to drive again now they
might get out there they might go home
they might take their wife's car and
drive again the next two hours later
nobody can control that they'll just get
picked up again if they're weaving and
then if they get arrested the second
time it's much more
serious but if you if you see the forms
that I'm talking about you will see that
there's all kinds of conditions and
there's
always um no excessive use of alcohol no
use of narcotic drugs or Controlled
Substances I always check those off and
I always give them a time limit as to
when they can drive again and that's
that's what I could do that's what a
judge could do there's really nothing
more you can
do unless you you and I for for an a DWI
offense especially if it's like a first
offense I'm not going to be sending him
to jail for 12 hours that would I think
be frowned upon by the court and that no
judge would do that is is that what you
is that what you are thinking yes that
answer my question thank you because our
our jails aren't that big we can't hold
that many
people thank you um representative Stone
if you if you could just in um in New
Hampshire we have a a protective custody
statute that allows the police to hold
them until they're sober and safe is
that not the case I was just curious to
see if we have a policy or directive
that if someone's intoxicated or
incapacitated by drugs are they actually
understanding what they're doing at the
time they're bailed and if they take
their conditions and throw them in the
circular file and later on are they
going to claim that they didn't know
what they were doing and had no
knowledge of it I guess that's an issue
some other states have faced and uh
sometimes I know at least in the state
of Vermont they end up not setting bail
until the individual is coherent unable
to understand their conditions represent
Muse one of one of the things that we've
heard uh several times from Bill
Commissioners is the the uh the claim
that the current statute ties their
hands so i' I've heard a number of of
folks who testified say that you know I
must do a PR bail in in this
situation as as I read uh as I read the
statute though uh it seems like a person
can be held if uh it's felt that the
court um uh feels that there's a danger
uh to the safety of the public if this
person is
released so you know I've I've got kind
of a conflict I keep hearing on the one
hand that folks don't have discretion to
hold people on the other hand I see in
the statute um that they do and what I'm
what I'm curious about
is what's what's the filter that causes
you to exercise that level of discretion
in some cases but not in others and I'm
you know I'm thinking that you know
nailing the door shut with a woman in
the bathroom and shoving her in there
that that seems to be a case where you
might want to exercise the discretion to
hold a person over to see a judge rather
than just PR bailing them and it looks
like the statute gives you the ability
to do that and so why
not yes and especially if you have
directions from the court not to because
that's who you answer to so let if we
could hear
that that would not happen now
because they have added a
section the that's why I want you to
look at the forms because there's now a
section where if you
are if you want to hold someone in jail
I can now do that but I have to kind of
hold a hearing with myself and then
write in my reasons for holding them
because everything kind of defaults to
release and if you want to hold or
um do something other than do a PR
release you you kind of have to do an
exp a wordy explanation of
why and I I do hold
people you
know but there was a period of time when
bail reform came in that we were
specifically told that ba PR bail was
zero dollar and there would be no cash
bail and that unless something were
really
drastic they weren't to be sent up to
Valley Street or wherever the county
court is but that changed again it's
it's fluid things have been you know I
think Co had a big big effect on that
because we couldn't go into police
stations for a while and the court was
closed for months you know it was it was
like a scramble and now we're kind of
coming out of that and the rules change
every every year when I go to a bail
Commissioners meeting which there's one
coming up in
October um we hear
about something new you you know I
remember judge Derby saying to us at one
of the meetings if somebody has
transgressed the same thing like if
they've if they've been arrested for
whatever it is three times in a row
within five
years go directly to jail and wait wait
to be bailed by the judge actually I
think what you're referring to is if
someone has failed to appear no it's he
was was beyond that it was
if well it was he had
said
yeah yeah or assaults I mean you know
like domestic violence assaults what's
interesting is I don't believe the
statute has changed um since 2018 but
your instructions in the court seem to
be what is fluid and and that seems to
change um the other thing is two years
ago when I started started doing
telephonic baales for do and
Rochester I had already gone to my once
a year October bail Commissioners
meeting in miramac because that's in our
circuit and then I got an invitation to
go to the one in over so I responded and
said that yes I will go so I went
and it was just
very enlightening to me the different
ways that the different courts actually
perceive what we are supposed to be
doing
and for instance one thing that stuck
out in my head is there's a line and
this goes back to bail commissioner fees
but it says bail commissioner fee $40
and then it has a box to check off paid
unpaid and then there's a couple other
things so I brought this up to the judge
in do because I hadn't ever been paid
for any of my telephonic ones out of DOA
or or Rochester which is her kind of
circuit and she said oh I never noticed
that and I said oh that's surprising
because it's right next to where you
have to sign off on the
paperwork you know it's it's like so now
I make a great big ass is the size of a
quarter and I write pay fee at court in
handwriting and now I start to get
paid you know but it's
like aren't they supposed to read these
this paperwork you know if I may ask how
do you get paid from the court do they
they send you a check from the the state
of New Hampshire how does that work if
if the court collects the
fee then they remit it to New hampsh
ampire judicial branch administrative
whatever and that all gets
aggregated and I get a check and
sometimes I'll get it's interesting
because sometimes I'll get a check for
$40 or sometimes I'll get two of them on
the same check sometimes I'll get two
checks in the same
envelope I mean and and the other thing
you talk about communication all
right I recently L changed my post
office
box and I advised the administrative
court and I asked Vicki day I said who
should I tell its Superior Court and she
said well she said you're going to have
to tell every Court you do business
with what your change of address is and
I said well why I said the checks all
come out of one
place she said because when they do the
paperwork and they send the money
in your
$40 has to be directed by them to go to
a specific
address so the and they never get rid of
the old address so so the finance people
who cut the check don't maintain your
information they just each individual
it's crazy
yeah I mean this whole system needs an
organizational person more than a rules
person yeah yeah well sometimes the rule
will make an organizational person
appear thank you um any further
questions this witness has got up
several times right thank you uh and
next thank you very much now I'm going
to ask you to start because I believe
you and I had a discussion is where I
got this concept of having to mail some
paperwork in so if you could begin with
that I'd appreciate it it might help my
my
reputation good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee thank you
for allowing me the opportunity my name
is Paul liry I live in Franklin New
Hampshire I'm appointed as a bail
commissioner out of the Franklin Circuit
Court which at the time was a Franklin
District Court which was only this much
room rather than this much room
currently when we have to write the
checks that's a story for another
day one of the things that I keep
hearing is people forget bail
Commissioners are directed to do two
things in the paperwork that we hand out
I'm supposed to reasonably assure that
the defendant will appear in court and
then by clear and convincing evidence
that he won't
reoffend if he's going to be in that
reoffending mode that's when we check
off preventative detention and they go
down to the jail and they see the judge
within 24 to 48 hours depending if it's
District of superior
court at least in the Circuit Court bail
La of form forms we have room to write
My reasonings down so the judge would
see why I did what I did and the
superior court it's just a checkbox and
the county attorney's office takes that
over so the thing is I've been almost 35
years in law enforcement and Public
Safety and I'm 7 and a half years as a
bail commissioner so about 43 and a half
years of playing the
game and I have a lot of repeat
customers I am seeing children
grandchildren and great grandchildren of
people that I dealt with out on the
street and I'm now working with children
and grandchildren of police officers
that I worked for when I was out there
so I've been around I've seen a lot and
the biggest thing that happened and uh
Judy kind of alluded to it was in 2018
when we had the big bail
reform everyone slammed the brakes on
and everyone was afraid to do something
well I'm old school because I spent the
time in law enforcement when you got a
question where do you go back to the
rules you know go look at the reason why
the legislature did what they did what
does the RSA say how did it
affect and then we also had to follow
what the court was giving us for
direction and was correct all we had was
PR bail before it used to be PR bail and
there was room for an amount there was a
period at the end of PR bail they didn't
want a number amount on it because
before we do PR bailing we'd set an
amount just to let them know that if it
ever ended up as a cash situation that's
what it could
be and the days that the $25,000 and
$50,000 cash bails
disappeared and we started seeing people
that I was bailing out for $25 $50
$100 and if it was civil $121
123 and you try to find pennies nickels
and dimes since I was a paper boy back
about 60 years ago I haven't carried
that little change thing on my my my
belt so I mean there's a lot of things
that are out there that go into it but I
think some of the things that I've heard
a lot of them are
communication it's like I heard talk
about probation and parole well because
I was police officer I understand if I
couldn't get a hold of the probation and
parole officer I would call prison
control and I would leave a message with
prison control to let the uh po or the
probate the parole officer know that
there was requesting a 72-hour hold from
the bail commissioner and it would be
done and I have usually we'll tell the
police departments if we want to hold
them on a 72-hour hold to reach out to
prison control and make that phone call
and leave the message once it's done we
can check the box off so we've had some
you know luck with doing things like
that uh a few things that I've heard
here about mailing stuff uh faxing stuff
and uh snail
mail snail mail when I used to be able
to send a letter out of Franklin in of
the day I could get it into lonia
conquer or Manchester without a problem
it's now four to six days to get it to
them so we have to keep that in
mind in other words when I do the bail
paperwork I take the bail paperwork Fold
It Up put it in an envelope that I have
to buy on paper that I had to buy with
ink that I had to pay for to make the
form to send it out and then put the
stamp on it and the stamp keeps getting
more and more expensive and then that
goes to the court now that's for almost
everything however if I have someone
that I'm holding
overnight I
email to the courts now the problem is
for all the Superior Courts we have a
direct one from Bales at in the name of
the Court and we send it to them so they
have it so first thing in the morning
when they get in there it's there with
the circuit CAU they do everything by
facts well I haven't had an analog phone
line in my house in over 10 years so I'm
not paying $40 to $80 a month to have a
service so I can send a fax to the court
because again I only get paid 62 to 68%
of the time but I do take credit card
for bail and pay the
$149 I looked at it this way $38 51
cents was better than no cense at all so
you know it's one of those things that
you just start balancing if I may just
pause for a sec so we heard some people
um say that well no no no you it's not
mailed it's fax that's not mandatory so
if you don't have a fact uh no I that's
why I email in other words you learn how
to get around what has to be done to
make it happen and if not sometimes what
I'll do is I'll have the police
department fax the form for me to the
court to make sure that it's there when
it's domestic violence it's pretty much
spelled out I'm required to send to the
court that and I send the ones that I
know by email the others I have the
police department if it's on Friday
night until Monday morning or Tuesday
morning if it's a holiday at 8: a.m. the
police departments are supposed to fax
that information to State Police and
state police will atically put it into
the National Registry on domestic
violence and that's one of the first
things that shows up on the criminal
records that we have an opportunity to
see part of the things that you're
talking about having access there's a
thing called sieges it's the federal
regulations that say we're not sworn
officers of the you know law enforcement
so we're not entitled to it however
there is an exception in seis as a bail
commissioner I can review but I can't
keep they give me it I read it take my
notes I give it back or they read it to
me over the phone so I can have the
information I need so the thing is
that's happening but where it gets
problematic is right now I'm bailing in
nine counties because of Co I've done
over a thousand of the remote or tele
baings and you finally work around them
and you make it work some of them we do
FaceTime some of them we do Zoom but
some of them don't have the connectivity
so we do it over the telephone in other
words there is a way to make it work but
it becomes a challenge the smaller
police departments don't have access
directly to any of that if they go
through a larger Police Department or a
county because of sieges requirements
they can't fax it to them they can't
email it to them they can read it to
them but the problem is if there's only
one dispatcher on they don't have the
time to be able to do that so that
becomes a catch
22 and so sometimes the quick way to
skirt it is because about roughly 95% of
the people when you ask them straightly
are you a convicted felon yeah you on
probation appr Pro yeah and they'll
answer and you know when you're going
like it that pretty much you got a
pretty good idea when you start checking
off conditions that you're going to want
and the thing is it's nice to have your
hand on the
criminal record but the thing is
sometimes it's just not available so you
figure out other ways to do it if the
statute changed that you did have to
swear not for in whatever capacity you
would then be able to your understanding
access sieges the sieges has to do with
Federal that's that's all the federal
agencies that State Police signs off and
then the police department sign off to
be able to right get that but parole
information officers have access to it
correct I'm not sure yeah I believe they
are so if if we were to make sure that
the statute provided you with the
necessary um access access or or
necessary to fulfill the federal
requirement for you to access it I guess
I'm getting at is it would it be better
if you could just have those see it in
real time because I know if you got a an
arreste from say MK because that's one
of our closest states with the most
population you could have someone with a
10-page record and no one's reading you
that over the phone and and each record
each each um line on the record will
have information like default default
picked up you'll know their history of
it does and it doesn't because each one
of the states are different and I'm
telling you when you read some of those
I have no clue when they were arrested
if they ever saw a judge what the
outcome was or anything because it's not
spelled out as neatly as Oz is but it
took o a long time to get so when you
looked at the criminal record you could
actually figure out what was going
on but
uh
and the thing is with the uh requirement
to 24 to 48 hours holding that's
excluding weekends and holidays but yet
if like for Thanksgiving where they have
Thanksgiving and the Friday off the
court is required to hold bail hearings
on the Saturday because of the amount of
time that they'd be
held so and that's at the courthouse is
open on Saturday during those occas I
don't know what they do I'm having a
funny feeling that that's probably all
On video okay in other words they have
the ability to do it and I think what
the committee is picking up is there's a
lot of
compartmentalization in other words you
know what you guys do and but beyond
that that's really you know their what
they do and then before what happens
before they see you is something else
and then what you each do is a little
bit different absolutely and if you
listen to us each one of us came on at a
different time frame when I came on my
training was I had to follow a bail
commissioner to see two baales first one
was a be misdemeanor which is a non-
jailable offense doesn't need a lawyer
so you what you need to know in a
circuit court bail order four pages the
next one was a civil bond which was a
one page at that point I was blessed go
forth and have fun and it was a School
of Hard
Knocks the training was catches catch
can some of it was good used to be when
they changed the paperwork that's when
we'd get training and we'd be trained on
how the paperwork what the court was
looking for in the paperwork and that
was what they were concerned about after
the legislature put in that we required
training the first training we had
lasted 21 minutes it was over a video I
sat at the conquered District Court
Judge Kelly was presiding and
the hookup or link didn't
work so needless to say it was a
disaster and then we at least had two
judges sitting there and says well guys
we're here do you have any questions and
then some training happened uh and
particularly where I'm in Franklin I'm
the only bail Commissioner of wrecked
that was basically came out of Franklin
the others are out of Lone or out of
conquer that they're coming up and
helping and covering so the thing is I
usually end up either in conquer or in
Laconia now last year lon's training we
had the clerk two Deputy clerks because
it was both Franklin and and lonia but
they share the same clerk two judges and
the bail Commissioners we went for
almost two hours and it was the best
training that I've had in basically
seven years so the thing is it's again
catches catch can depends upon the
clerks and sometimes we get the
administrative office of the Court where
either the administrator of the superior
court or of the circuit court gets
involved in the training and a little
bit more actually happens
it's like the ID card you said we were
supposed to get I got it in an an 8 and
a half by 11 page with this little tiny
thing up in the corner that looked like
someone in the kindergarten had done it
and I was told to use that as my
identification as a bail commissioner
with all due respect my business card
looked more professional than that so
the thing is just because the law is
made doesn't mean when it finally gets
down to
the people that are doing the work on
the ground
that it has the effect that you want it
to have the things that I think you
heard Judy mention and uh others you
want to think of the
consequences if you take and add
domestic violence on there and you're
talking about the misdemeanor side of it
sometimes that's telling you the nature
of the the offense take for instance I'm
in Bristol and I'm bailing someone and I
decide to hold
them or not there's that chance but the
way you you excuse
me the way you've written the law it
says sha so it's a snowy night one
officer on and he's got to go all the
way up to North haval to where the
county jail is or if you get someone in
the bottom of Coos County in the middle
of a snowstorm they got to go all the
way up to the top of Stewart's toown
almost up to the Pittsburgh Town Line
where the county jail is there is impact
on the rural side of this in the small
police departments where there's only
one officer out if you're lucky and if
it's after 11:00 1:00 in the morning
they may be on call covered by State
Police and we know they're severely
under staff as is the county there may
not be anything until that officer gets
called out and finally gets there so
there's there's a lot of things in play
that you want to take a look at the list
I would have referred you back to the uh
the website for bail Commissioners there
used to be a bail Commissioners manual
out there I still have my 2016 that I
printed off but I knew I could get the
2020 that was out on the website well
probably about four or five months ago
they took that down so I'm still using
my
2016 but inside that book there are four
things that are listed that we can't
write bail for and some of it's the
homicide and some of those things and AR
rest is left to our discretion and I
think the key to it and everyone keeps
coming back to it it's
training and so that there is a
consistency throughout the state I'll
just throw this in here just to add a
monkey wrench in since you're going to
talk to
finance there was a thing to put on 15
magistrates to replace 100 bail
Commissioners that do do it basically
for nothing and provide all their own
equipment uh and there was a caveat that
you would hire someone to train the
magistrates the money has already been
talked about so if you took that
money use that person to train the bail
Commissioners and then they got I think
$1.6 million to pay for the 15
magistrates the support staff and their
benefits and all of that stuff and gave
that a seed money to go into the court
system so that they could pay pay the
bail commissioner for everything we
wrote every two weeks send us a check at
the end of the year give us a $199 we're
still an agent we're not an employee and
everyone's happy and your bail
Commissioners are getting paid at
whatever the statutory rate is but with
the postage keep going up and gas keep
going up you're probably going to have
to look at that $40 rate because you
stop and think we're not getting it 100%
of the time at this point and you speak
about equipment I'm now on my second
iPad 12 you know the iPad Pro that I do
my bailing on with the you know the
fancy keyboard I've had to buy two I'm
on my second portable printer because I
burned my first one out so the thing is
those go at450 and the iPads are almost
$1,000 so the thing is this these are
all things that we provide for ourselves
I'm always going out and getting a case
of you know 10 RS of paper so that I
have the paper on hand to print all the
forms that I use because I print them as
I go so I mean you got a dedicated group
out here but all of a sudden we start
reading that the legislature wants to do
away with with the bail
Commissioners uh Judge Lynn who was the
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court the
superior court now legislature wanted to
put on three Circuit
Court judges and do away with bail
Commissioners because that'd be enough
to handle it so and it gets kind of
discouraging for those of us that get up
365 it's like this morning I got a call
at 3:15 in the morning to do a bail and
I still had to get up to be here because
I thought it was important enough to be
here to give you information that I
think that you need before you make
decisions about what bail Commissioners
are and I'm glad to see you haven't
called us bail bondsman that's the first
time in several years coming down here
since 2019 that we haven't been referred
to that because it was one put in by a
senator of one of the bail Commissioners
specifically to help the bail
Commissioners and it said an act
relative to bail
bondsman and then it was amended and
Commissioners I um I can't I can't speak
to that but I can tell you that we at
least uh read the law before we start
talking about changing it so he won't be
called a bondsman in here um and we
appreciate it and I hope that you heard
my earlier statement this committee has
no interest in attacking the
Commissioners we don't blame the
Commissioners this is a systemic issue
um the Commissioners are a huge part of
it but it's not just the Commissioners
it's the it's all the other agencies as
well and that and that's the PO when you
go go into you have to remember as a
bail commissioner I'm making a decision
at that point in time that's a snapshot
of what I'm seeing what I've read what
I've heard from the officers and I've
gathered sometimes it's like pulling ey
teeth out of a saber-tooth tiger to get
the information you need to really do a
good job with the
bail and then it goes to the
court the prosecutor the judge the
County Attorney they're all involved in
that process I hold them in preventative
detection mention because I'm hoping
that the judge will hold them and in the
circuit court at least I've been able to
tell the judge why I held them in the
past pre 20108 if I held someone they'd
usually be a week anyway before they had
a bail hearing schedule to change that
now they're usually out the next morning
so the thing is it becomes a revolving
door and the bail Commissioners always
seemed to be the punching bag because we
were the one that did the paperwork
and it's like paperwork is the paperwork
as she said and if you actually got to
see the forms you might understand is
this is the paperwork that we have to
give to the court and that's all we send
them and like I say in the circuit court
at least we have the opportunity on the
bottom of the page to say why we put
them but it's only four lines and it's
hard to get everything in in four
lines agreed and um we do appreciate the
reference we will be circulating those
documents among we're going to make sure
sure that we see what it is that you
actually just make sure you leave T Bale
in there that's a good thing yeah
because otherwise it'd be police
departments that would be still making
phone calls I got a call from one over
in Rochester I was the 20th call they
placed for find a bail commissioner so
bail Commissioners as a bail
commissioner you can just say n not
tonight I'm not I'm not taking it you
can decline yeah um so yeah well some
just don't answer the phone but I was
always taught I know what it is I answer
the phone and I'll tell them why and are
you on call um
247365 so on a holiday if you decide you
know what I'm going to have a I'm going
to have a couple Elations to celebrate
you've kind of Taken yourself off the
market and no one knows if someone else
is there to fill it and yeah as the
expression goes that's not my problem
yeah other words I was set to bail out
at a Franklin
District it's small area but it kind of
got up into Grafton County went into a
little bit more in belnap County a
little further out in meramac county and
then it kind of became the six circuit
which goes out into Hillsboro down into
hookit and kind of taking that out and
then Co hit and it became Statewide
because once state troopers start to
learn that someone is willing to do the
paperwork and set up and figure it out
they passed the word and it gets into
police departments dispatch centers and
your phone keeps
ringing the punishment for doing your
job yeah any questions oh I see a few
okay represent will oh represent Stone
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question from an operational
standpoint since you've been doing this
for a while do you think it's feasible
that since Hamshire has 13 cities and
over 200 Towns at 15 magistrates will be
able to keep up with the case load of
what you currently have is approximately
100 bail
Commissioners well here's this the cold
hard fact you got 15 people that have
gone to work Monday through Friday from
8:00 to 4: and you got 100 people that
are working 24/7 365 and doesn't cost
the state
anything run the
numbers we are cost effective and the
thing is everything that I hear is one
part of misinformation because people
don't understand the biggest problem for
us is communication with the court and
being able to get a hold of somebody at
3:00 in the morning when I've got
something that makes absolutely no sense
because I can't read what the judge
wrote that's why I went out and I got
the iPad so there was no thing so I
can't tell the defendant what when I'm
trying to release him what that is
because I can't read it and yes we've
complained up through the administrative
office of the court and numerous times
and we don't get phone calls back they
just plain don't answer us I know we're
lower than whale crap we're at the
bottom of the peack and order we
understand understand that and we deal
with it but you know the thing is the
only time I think I'll hear from them if
I screw something up
maybe so um that brings up an
interesting question is the very fact
that you're having to decipher
handwriting um it's that it's not
electronically printed out you're
actually reading like doctor's
prescriptions uh at 3 in the morning uh
no doctor's prescriptions I can usually
figure out because it looks like my
handwriting this is even more worse I
mean it's just it's like a pen just
pencil one writes in pencil and it lays
it on the side and it's kind of Flowery
and it just becomes a smudge across the
paper you can't read anything we had six
people trying to figure it out at the
jail one night and it was someone that
we really didn't want to
release but we couldn't tell them what
they were supposed to do and where they
couldn't go because we couldn't read
it so we went back to the police
department and we got the original
information we're able to in other words
we made it happen because we know that
there's other ways to do it but it's not
it's a great straightforward way we
should have basically a clerk available
to us or a judge available to us 247
like the police do so if we get
something that's never happened before
or how to deal with it we at least have
someone to run something by we used to
have that with the older judges that
have since retired the newer
judges they no hey that's your job you
set the bail we don't do that so I can't
advise you I'm not looking for
advisement on what I'm going to do I'm
looking for process and you deal deal
with process so that's some of the
challenges that we've had not everyone
has it but I'm also an advocate for in
other words when I go down when
someone's coming into the jail with you
know cash bail they wait an hour usually
before someone gets there but they've
had to wait until they've processed all
the money through made sure everything
was there that they weren't the
protected party or someone they had to
stay away with before they call us so
once we get down there so I'm more
concerned about the bailing party that's
come down or driven up we've had them
come up from Massachusetts and they
couldn't get a bail commissioner and
they had to go away and come back
another day because of that you know
there's all kinds of things that are
going on out there that shouldn't but
they do and it's like it's the totality
of what you need to look at but I think
what you've heard from some take a a
good hard look at the laws and see how
they're going to affect anything north
of
hookit because as you start to go up
north or you get over to the western
side of the state or the Eastern going
up things change dramatically once the
population goes down is the tax baces
that are supporting those police
departments they're not very large and
some of the courts are not full-time
courts they're part-time courts so they
don't have a regular
schedule at least with Superior Court we
know but the we have to guess especially
if the police officers don't know that
becomes challenging so you could set a
court date for a defendant to appear
that there may not even be a judge there
that day so what I do is I cheat I find
the biggest town that's 24 hours in that
court and I call and give me a valid
court date so at least I know that on
that date there's going to be a judge
there there may be an unhappy prosecutor
but at least we get them in to see the
judge on a valid court date or sometimes
what the court will do is they'll mail a
new court date to the person because
they'll realize that there is no judge
available it sounds like um perhaps new
judges need to Shadow a bail
commissioner instead of it goes back to
the thing it's it's training for all of
us so that we all understand and then
sometimes it maybe is the old addage
years to go you get the judges the bail
Commissioners and the police and the
prosecutors together and have the
conversation and so that that way
everybody gets to hear the same thing at
the same time and it makes things a lot
easier for
everyone don't worry you'll be back
representative wheeler thank you Mr
chair um this seems like such a
thankless job I'm curious as to what
initially attracted you to want to
become a bail commissioner and how we
could get truth younger or more people
to to do what you have served the public
to do for the the other last however
many years honest nothing actually
attracted me to being a bail
commissioner I'm a retired police chief
and I had three police Chiefs come to me
and say we need a bail commissioner
you've been retire a year can you help
us how could I say no because having
been a police chief I was at the mercy
of bail Commissioners because they were
unavailable so it was like well yeah
that's how I did it but on the flip side
I'm getting older this forces me to keep
my brain active I have to stay up on the
statutes I like to read them so that I
understand the nuances and the things is
what I can do and after the bus settled
on the 2018 bail reform I went back and
I looked at the law the law hadn't
really changed it was the attitude of
how we were looking at things had
changed and we just started sliding
things in because I was asked to go down
to Manchester to bail and one night I
was there I sent I think three people
preventative detention to Valley Street
jail sent one on 5,000 cash and one on
10,000
cash and I didn't get a note from the
caught or
anything so the thing is it's you know
it's doable but the thing is we have to
justify what we've done and I have to be
able to explain if I get called by the
judge why I did what I did so the thing
is everything we do is you got to do it
objectively you can't be subjective
about it you got to have the facts in
front of you and based on those facts
you make the condition that certain
things need to be done and if you can't
quite get them to jail it might be cash
bail might be the better way to do it
because if they can raise the money they
don't but if they can't they still go to
jail then they see the judge so the
thing is the end result you get almost
the same
thing I appreciate your testimony and
I'm more sure we'll be conducting these
hearings first and next month so I'm
sure we'll see you again and uh we'll
have more questions oh oh I'm sorry
representative gaff
right thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I'm just curious
because I remember that there was a bill
from the Senate um where they wanted to
make sure that the Commissioners got
paid and I know that the Commissioners
came and basically told us not to vote
for the bill which we did listen and um
we basically killed the bill but I'm
just not trying to understand why was it
that the commissioner did not want um
the state to intervene to make sure you
received your your fees of
$40
inre that will
beached
notun let's fix and get us paid first
before you start increasing fees or
adding fees that
we so um you felt like it was going to
jeopardize getting being paid for your
bail fees in the first place by asking
for even more um and then then they also
the flip side was can we bring it up to
$50 no leave it at $40 just pay us the
$40 but that was that was before the
last three years of extreme expenses so
the thing is you probably going to have
to revisit that if this thing doesn't
change there's a post postage when I
started I think was 40 some OD cents
it's now 66 cents and the thing is you
talk about nickel and diamond where I've
showed you that I'm over $51,000 in the
hole since I've been doing this so the
thing is plus supplies and everything
else that $40 isn't $40 in
reality and then when you figure only 60
to 62 to 68% collecting that's part of
the challenge so to go back to your
question again we're the only ones in
the Judiciary that don't get paid on a
regular basis and when we go out to to
do the work we don't know whether we
will or we won't because we I was told
at least I can't ask do they have the
bail fee because that's grounds from my
termination I was told however I know
that there are bail Commissioners that
ask and say no I'm not coming out and
they hang
up just so I do it I want to do a
listening check you have been doing this
for seven years just the baill seven and
a half seven and A2 and in seven and A2
years you are 50 $1,000 in the whole in
just bail fees not talking about your
own expenses and mileage or anything
else $5
51,3 to be exact and that was as of uh
23 it's gone up since
then thank you represent GA did you have
a
[Music]
followup so with that said um have you
um actually talked to to anyone in the
senate about that
$40 fee in terms of a bill to address
that issue since you did not want the
one that you said was related to um
traveling that was mileage yes we were
told that it would be taken care
of how's that working
out see that was the nicest way I think
I could put it and not put my foot in up
past my kneecap just curious thank you
ioke to
melie she was faor of getting us our
money but it was just trying
to you know get it through the
committee the committee
just
it just got so far a field and started
concentrating other exous things I
remember the chief in Rochester was on
and he
testified what was he said something
about we might as well turn this whole
thing
over cash and I'll never
forget because it is I mean somebody he
they some guy that was doing bur eight
times one day
and and that's when it
started you know was three
times thank you
just it's not you know it's not ever
been I don't think well out
that's what we're trying to do just just
so
you but but again A lot has to do too is
the police departments if they happen to
ask can you hold this person and then
actually tell you why and not have to
fight to get it out of them because I
had a one where I bailed up in havil
gentlemen had all kinds of stuff and
they wanted PR bail
had no criminal record had nothing so I
mean there was you know just nothing
that you could say that you could meet
the requirements to hold him well the
nice thing was after I let him out on
conditions he must have found a spot to
hang out until he could go pick up his
vehicle which was on a 24-hour hold or
12-hour hold and he got in the car and
left havil and went into
pedmont and he got stopped
there and the chief happened to stop and
he noticed he saw the bail paperwork so
he called me he says I've got this
person said for
what and he said would you be open to
holding him I said well there was no
doubt about that I just told him he
couldn't do all of that and we haven't
even got 12 hours
here so he went up to the Grafton County
jail so the thing is it a lot of times
it's
situational it sounds like that was luck
I mean had he not seen the bail
paperwork to know that that guy was on
bail that where he called me so I mean
otherwise so another bail commissioner
would have been in the same thing
there's no record with no record it's
hard to but then again within 12 hours
you got a little bit to build something
depending upon the nature of the crimes
too and you know some things there
they're what you call
no-brainers you know like the door
nailed up you know that that's kind of
like no you definitely need to see
somebody and it's above my pay grade so
preventative detention and it seems that
he was going to go back and try it again
so that goes to show that yeah okay no
would have been a right call thank you
you're welcome all right thank you for
your testimony um I believe that's it
for the bail Commissioners um and I
think um you'll agree with me we've had
a lot of enlightening testimony and a
lot of information um so I'm going to
give everybody a little homework before
we meet again
um yeah yes please um have a have a this
is what you can copy it if you want
that's what we're going to do it's just
what I give out to all the telic towns
okay they call
me I
don't okay thank I appreciate that just
so you know
circuits
okay anybody they have their own
emails
so yeah they have a fax machine spit
somebody has to pick it up okay thank
you so for your homework um I'd like you
everyone please if you could go to that
website and look at those forms so that
we can have an intelligent discussion uh
tomorrow about about those forms and and
um I'll I'll figure out tonight where to
take us tomorrow I think we've heard
enough about the the crimes I think we
need to one thing we haven't discussed
is flight we've talked a lot about
dangerousness
I'd like to discuss Flight Risk of
flight there's the two grounds someone
could be held on that they're a danger
to themselves or the community or their
risk of flight so we haven't heard much
about flight so tomorrow we're going to
talk a little bit about that and we'll
see where that starts that that
conversation takes us tomorrow um as I
said next Thursday um we have a
representative from Finance is going to
come in here so I'd like to have a kind
of a a conceptual idea of how much money
we may need and what for so far we know
that we are going to definitely and I
hope you all agree with me that we're
not leaving here unless we we have these
these people paid um that I'm done with
that um so that's going to be um part of
it and um I we're going to be asking for
some money um for the technology piece I
think we may have to temporarily fund a
few positions in the court and the way
that would work is we would ask them to
tell us how much it would cost for X Y
and Z employees until your next budget
year and then it's up to you to put it
in your budget to to redo it right so
we're going to we're going to have to
put together a ballpark and then as we
get towards the end of the process at
the end of October I hope to put some um
some real numbers together to ask for
and justify and um let's let's leave
this better than we we found it um and
so we don't have to talk about it
anymore um really next year we could
just maybe deal with
crime homework homework yeah the
homework is to look look at the um look
at those forms that that she pointed us
to that have S well no she's if you go
to the there's a link I'll someone if
someone gets it
could yeah okay oh
yes um since it's I'm gonna ask our
committee assistant um if she'll print
it out for everybody that you don't have
to you spend enough money um we we have
our own reams of paper we can
use yeah um if you if you want to
because I didn't see her
in yeah that that would be helpful I
appreciate that thank you very much and
anything else that occurs to you
overnight that we haven't heard um bring
it and we'll talk about it and with that
um um I think that's all the homework we
can do well we'll have some more
homework over over the longer period
till we meet again on Thursday and we'll
decide where we're going to go next week
week um yes
sir Senate Bill 112 from which
year um Brad could you Brad could you um
send us a link for that I appreciate it
thank you does anyone else have anything
else to say before we break yes I just
want to apologize to our clerk really
quickly because I know he's watching I
did not eat this and and I just brought
it in here I will not bring food into
the committee I didn't even see I just
saw it I get that off I appreciate it
thank you um never bring muffins unless
you have one for each of us and only
pass them out during the break and Mr
clerk I'm sorry um with that um everyone
please enjoy your
evening